ciao ragazzi
oggi nuova challenge è una delle
challenge più richieste di questo mese e
cioè baldi ha nascosto gli ingredienti
slime devo trovare tutti gli ingredienti
slime nascosti da ubaldi dopo che avete
visto il video in cui cremi ha nascosto
tutti gli ingredienti slam dovrebbe
recuperare tutti gli ingredienti slang
da g mi avete scritto in migliaia di
fare lo stesso ma con baldi
quindi cosa dovremmo fare dovremo
recuperare sette notebooks quindi 7
quadernini in cui ci saranno delle
formule matematiche da risolvere
se riusciamo a risolverli potremmo
prendere l'ingrediente slime l'obiettivo
è prendere tutti e sette i quaderni in
autobus prendere tutti e sette gli
ingredienti e creare lo slime senza
essere presi da balti secondo voi ce la
farò se volete vedere un secondo
episodio
lasciate un bel mi piace a 40 mila mi
piace si sarà il secondo episodio di
baldi ha nascosto gli ingredienti slime
e l'altro episodio in cui grenier nasco
sono impegnati cm quasi 50.000 vi piace
quindi dopo questo video andati a
vederlo
ma ora siete pronti a iniziare la
challenge chissà se sarà inquietante
come g io penso di no perché secondo me
non c'è nessuno più inquietante di
graham i ma non si sa mai
allora innanzitutto iniziamo ad
esplorare questo stato e vediamo se c'è
qualcosa che fa al caso nostro
allora vediamo un po che cos'è quella
scritta lì c'è scritto regole della
scuola non correre non mangiare perché
non bere ma insomma fai silenzio io ho
infranto questa regola e non scappare
dal castigo
oddio quindi qualcuno mi potrebbe
mettere in castigo non sapevo che baldi
mettesse anche in cattivo le persone gli
studenti
oddio ma ad aprire quella porta evitiamo
che cosa c'è io penso che baldi non ti
rincorra come g quindi forse devo
semplicemente fare silenzio non farmi
vedere
non lo so proviamo ad aprire la porta e
vediamo i ragazzi andiamo
ciao ciao berlin berlino è venuto a
salutarci di un po quasi sono due porte
oddio coinvolti ma anche per league un
po confuso gliele canta la mano ma
perché lui si muove insomma domani mi fa
morire il fratello visto perché si
muovono in modo che se mi avvicino mi fa
qualcosa
berlino perché non si muove adesso fatti
dei motivi fuso forse baldi non mi fa
niente che ha paura ma allora ti muovi
che ha detto qualcuno scuro benvenuti
nella mia scuola
ok signor baldi ora vado in questa
stanza per vedere se c'è qualcosa non so
cosa hai detto ma saper entrare in
questa stanza vediamo stesse qualche
notebook
non si arrabbi lui
ok rimaste incompiute per fortuna non è
che mi segue
no sembra di no ho paura che spunti la
all'improvviso
ok sembra tutto che quindi possiamo
vedere se qua avete visto è andato
nell'altra stanza
comunque vediamo se qua c'è un notebook
qua c'è un tavolino guardate eccolo qua
vi ho trovato il primo quadernino il
primo notebook è venuto anche berlino
controllare allora vediamo un po cosa
c'è scritto
ok ragazzi venivo cosa c'è nel nostro
primo quaderno vino ecco quali esercizi
di matematica quindi abbiamo 19 più 26
42 più 5 32 più 3 è l'ingrediente come
potete vedere qua e lo shampoo celeste
troppo se il gradiente equa e non potrei
semplicemente prendere l'ingrediente
senza esprimere qua e andarmene
tutto come fa baldi a sapere che non ho
completato gli eserciti può prendere
l'ingrediente stein senza completare gli
esercizi visto che non penso che baldi
se ne accorgerà mai quindi facciamo
silenzio continua ci sono portare ok
baldi se n'è accorto decisamente quindi
dobbiamo completare gli esercizi
altrimenti penso che non ci faccia
uscire da qua oppure si colpirà con il
suo righello qui dico perché amo questi
esercizi è il primo al diciannove più 26
all'altro
ok 45 mi sembra spero di non sbagliare
altrimenti boldi verrò a prendermi
subito a 42 più 5 47
si no 32 t3 35 cos'era quel rumore
forse vuol dire che posso finalmente
prendere l'ingrediente slime non ci
saranno problemi
ok l'ho preso proviamo ora ad aprire la
porta nervi che qualche stella nokia il
suo così si ok non c'è boldi quindi ce
l'abbiamo fatto abbiamo preso questo
primo ingrediente e ora proviamo andare
nell'altra ottima se lo faccio venendo a
colpirmi ma ho completato di esercizi
quindi non può farmi niente
mi fa paura
andiamo nell'altra stanza facciamo
e così eccolo è comparso un completi a
volerci prima vedere che cosa ci
contratti se compiuto questi esercizi
posso prendere la colla che mi serve
assolutamente e la ciotola e posso
iniziare a mettere la colla con lo
shampoo non vediamo speriamo che siano
fa che vedrà anche qua baldi guarda che
io devo completare esercizi e quindi non
fu allora che sono molto di spazi li
meno ma le basi sta controllando che li
faccio corretti anche berlino lo sento
la pressione addosso così allora come
più 469 più 10 19 34 12 stime lì non ti
preoccupare non ti preoccupare gli sta
completando lo ti preoccupare che ti
sbatte rimaste anche berlino vuole
vedere gli esercizi berlino vuole vedere
il quadernino dove aiutarmi anche lui
mi dispiace affatto un mistero che non
conosci la matematica 4 p 8 12 ho
sentito vuol dire che abbiamo sbloccato
anche la colla la ciotola e piva andando
via per fortuna
ok abbiamo già tre cose tra il nostro
slime però abbiamo completato solo due
quaderni quindi dobbiamo trovarne altri
cinque ok ora andiamo in un'altra stanza
vedere se riusciamo a trovare gli altri
quadernini o forse potrebbero anche
essere in questa stanza non lo so
berlino aiutami a trovare gli altri
quadernini berlino da è con il tuo fiuto
aiutami a trovare gli altri quadernini
ok non c'è baltico e mi fa un po paura
se la stanza a piedi o su spaventato
mera merlino servire insomma mi vuoi
spaventare non vedo partita nessuna
parte che si e merlino forse da qualche
parte ha già ottenuto la cercando rinato
a seguirmi
è sparito ok non voglio più entrare in
quella stanza perché so che se lui li
quindi cerchiamo cose se qualche altro
notebook
guardate caroli l'altra notebook quindi
questo è il terzo equa di amo la paletta
che ci serve assolutamente e the little
blu xvi a minor gola con la blue quindi
è perfetto allora vediamo un po esercizi
ci sono qua merino evento per aiutarvi
allora ok sono semplici anche questi per
fortuna
prendo spenna allora 12 merlino ma stai
facendo qui scrive anche tu ridevi
glitter ultimi giri ma poi arriva a
farvi perché gli oppressi senta come
tablet e gamberi dammi da me li merigo a
berlino ecco qua ragazzi ci siamo
rincorsi per un po ma alla fine sono
riuscito a recuperarli berlino non si fa
se non sbagli arriva e si arrabbia
perché prima devo completare gli
esercizi non puoi rubare gli ingredienti
abbiamo subito mettervi a posto prima
che torni molti allora dov'è finita la
mia pena dobbiamo completare questi
esercizi
[Musica]
no mi raccomando non rubare liete dal
tavolo no merlino no ci nascondiamo le
cose berlino sta osservando la
situazione 26 14 più cintano sbloccato
possa prendere anche i notebook e norma
e ios brullo sbloccato quindi non puoi
farmi niente 1 vi sono dimenticate di
prendere il terzo notebook coprendo
comunque già un bel po di cose spero di
trovare l'attivatore il prima possibile
non so perché baldi stoffe muli
ok ok abbiamo copiato alzano quando era
prossimo già stati non abbiamo aperto
quella porta proviamo
vediamo
non c'e nessun odio ti amo stare di qua
passate piccolo che viva ma madre chiesa
la porta perché
vediamo un po ok sono facili sicurezza
ma non si legge non si capisce niente
come faccio a capire cosa c'è scritto
qui è impossibile da risolvere questa
formula vi sono anche dimenticata la
pena quindi devo tornare a prenderla
stream pepati non sia la riesco ad
aspettarmi oddio bandiera che rispettava
molto come ha fatto trasportarti ma io
devo devono andare a prendere la penna
quindi non seguire per favore di seguire
che paura
ok ho preso la penna non so non so come
faccio a risolvere quella formula
matematica perché non si riescono a
leggere i numeri forse una trappola
fatta da alti oppure è un tranello tipo
devo scrivere zero o lo so non devono
aprire la porta e ricordiamo la meglio
dobbiamo stare molto attenti
sentito rumori di una porta
non mi sembra che ci sia adesso
aspetto momento bologna devo si sono
accorta quindi spero non mi disturbi più
perché devo riuscire a capire come
risolvere questa formula che lo si
capisce che cos'è allora guardiamo la
meglio bene assieme 2050 più 44
eccola cerchiamo di essere allora mi
sembra che questa sia 12 36 18 01 27 14
seri scola risolta non posso prendere le
palline e anche i nostri
ovviamente sarà il quarto quindi me ne
mancano solo tre e priva solo che è
molto difficile questo non so cosa devo
scrivere sicuramente un tranello
provo a scrivere
ma che dice ma prima parla se non so che
fare ho paura che se scrivi la risposta
sbagliata basi arriva all'improvviso e
mitili quel regalo gigante di legno tra
l'altro qua non è come ingressi che o
cinque giorni ma ho solo una possibilità
altrimenti si rinizia da capo e o per
siete voi cosa devo fare
che risposta devo mettere qua scrivetemi
nei commenti cosa dovevo parto che non
possono essere i vostri commenti ora
quindi andrò a scrivere che lingua parli
mal di se io mi devo concentrare ha
detto ok lo so che tu sei impaziente
perché sono stato troppo tempo nella
formula l'ultima formula ma non è che
magari potresti dirmi che cosa vuol dire
cosa vogliono dire questi numeri
capisco cosa vuol dire quello che stai
di centro non ti avvicinare troppo
io non so cosa fare non posso aspettare
qui ancora a lungo perché baldi si sta
arrabbiando come avete potuto vedere
quindi secondo me l'unica cosa che
potete fare è zero perché non vogliono
questi numeri non c'è neanche un più
bello c'è scritto niente
quindi io provo a scrivere 0 speriamo
bene
non c'è stato nessun suono sto con sir
o no ragazzi ho perso pensavo di essere
fortunato in questo challenge come
ingressi e riuscire a vincere ma ho
perso la molto più difficile di quanto
pensassi è molto più difficile di g
forse o forse sono io che non so giocare
dovete iscrivermi tutti i vostri
consigli nei commenti dovete aiutarmi
poi per riuscire a sconfiggere baldi
riuscirà a prendere tutti gli incrementi
dello zayed riuscirà a prendere tutti
aspetti quadernini quindi iscrivetevi
nei commenti come posso fare per vincere
questa challenge e se questo video
raggiunge i 40 mila mi piace parola
seconda parte in cui ci riprovo e spero
di riuscire a risolvere quella formula
matematica che non si capisce un bel
cavoletto di niente quindi per la
prossima sale per il secondo episodio
dovete aiutarmi voi scrivete tutti i
vostri consigli nei commenti se avete
già giocato a baldi su come faccio a
vincere e io li userò nel prossimo
episodio mi raccomando da sotto un bel
mi piace io mi sono divertita un sacco e
ora vi lascio qua quattro case lire su
cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
ciao
[Musica]